[Music]
I think
American policies are usually dictated
by amazing ignorance. In the case of
Libya, for example, I think that the
Americans who got involved and the
French
[Music]
Hello
Thinkerview. Greetings from Berkeley in
[Music]
California. I see that in principle, in
theory, America thinks it has a
free economy regulated by the
open market, but in reality, like everyone else, it's...
the dollar is
very weak because America imports
much more than it
exports,
and this system, which... isn't very, very
solid. We've seen this in
recent crises, especially in 2007 and 2008.
In that crisis, not
only US banks, but
global banks had a crisis due to a lack
of capital, which was fueled by
illegal funds and black money, as
we say in English, from drug trafficking. We don't
know the extent of
drug trafficking, but we've
estimated that
perhaps
a billion dollars a year are
laundered through banks.  And there was
a United Nations officer who
said that there were banks that
would have failed during this crisis
if it hadn't been for this
remedy for illegal funds
in
drug trafficking. There are two ways to look at the
role of the war on drugs. For
me, the main, most important fact
is that the price of drugs is
much higher than it would be
if there weren't this war on drugs.
This means that the
big drug kingpins
approve of this war on
drugs because it's the source of their
profit, and drugs become like
a tax on ordinary people
that enriches the rich. And these funds end up
in
American banks. The banks make
specific arrangements to receive
these private funds. There's the
ordinary bank, and then alongside it, the
private bank that receives illegal fortunes,
like that of, for example, the brother of the
late president of Mexico. And so, the
result is that...
Drugs are even more
important to the economy
than they would be if we didn't have
this war on drugs.
Yes, it's true that
for states, when I talk about
California for example,
our number one
agricultural product is
marijuana, but it's true that there isn't
a tax on marijuana because it's
not legal. It's starting to change a little,
but in principle it's illegal, it's
not taxed,
and the government suffers.
The economy is different because
even if we're now talking about
heroin coming from
Afghanistan, the big profits aren't
made in
Afghanistan, the country of production; they're
in the country of consumption.
Because it's
estimated that maybe 80% or more
of the profit is made in those countries,
and even the other profits are
also banked in a country where the
banks are stable and guaranteed,
that is to say, the
United States. There have been two times when the
United States intervened in
Afghanistan. The first was against
the Russians and Soviets.
1979 and the second, obviously after September 11,
2001. The result of these two
interventions is that
Afghanistan, which has always had
opium, hashish, and marijuana,
but before the first
American intervention, was
n't a power in the
international market. Consumption was
local, and even the Americans went there to have a
safe drug experience in the 70s. It was what was
called the
Hippie Trail,
but from almost nothing in 1979
until now,
almost 90% of the international heroin
comes from Afghanistan, and even in the
United States, if I can add another
figure, the percentage of
heroin in the United States that came from
what is called the "crescent" outside
was zero in
1979, and according to the government, in
1980 it jumped to 60%.
[Music]
We see in Washington, there is this
big drug problem.  And there are
sociologists, doctors, all
sorts of experts who say that
the law really needs to be changed, and
especially, to begin with, that
marijuana should be legalized. But it's a taboo subject in
Washington. No one wants to discuss it if they want to
pursue a
political career; they shouldn't get involved in this
issue. And I think the reason is
because there's too much money and too much
profit coming from the
current situation. That's why it's
an example—not the
only one—where our democracy isn't working
because money prevents
discussion of real problems.
Drugs are truly one of the major
problems that are ruining
life in big
cities, the inner city as we
say in English.
And for 50 years we've waited for a
change in the laws, but it's a
taboo subject. Is it
because politicians
aren't free? Yes, they're free
to discuss it if they want, but they
know very well that it will be the end of
their careers, so that's why they
discuss it.
In my life, I've only spent six
months in Washington. I don't know
Washington very well, but I saw an
example in Congress of the
way in which you're not
allowed to talk about
drugs. I was part of a
secret committee. We received
speeches in a private room for
one of the House committees,
and the
chairman of that committee
told the committee that there was a word he
absolutely didn't want to
hear in the discussion, and that word
was legalization.
I wondered why, but
later I did some research. I found
that this representative in the House
had a brother. What do we
say is,
he was a lawyer, and in his
law firm, he had a very important
client. He was one of the biggest
drug kingpins in New York City.
So, he was a source of information about
someone who had been damaged, and drugs
had been legalized. And that's why,
I believe, this individual,
who was a...  A rather important individual, by
the way, who didn't want to hear
the word "
legalization," it's true. There are also
large bureaucracies, like the DI, which
is in charge of preventing drug trafficking, and
like all the prisons, and all these
bureaucracies become part of the
system that governs the country. They don't want
change. It was like in
the 1920s in the United States
with Prohibition. It was becoming increasingly
obvious that
change was necessary, but at that time there was
also great resistance
coming from the bureaucracy. And elsewhere,
when alcohol was finally legalized, that's when
drug prosecutions intensified, and
people who previously looked for
alcohol were now
looking for marijuana for the
first time. It was right
after the end of
alcohol prohibition. I have a weakness:
I invent words from time to time,
like "deep politics," and
I also invented this phrase, "
superworld." There's an "underworld" in English.
and which exerts power over
the government below, but it's
much weaker than the power
over the government above. And
I call all this private force—
corporations, but also individuals,
the very rich—
uh, the very rich who are involved in
politics, I call them the
superworld. And in my
book, "The Road to World Disorder,"
I even gave a definition, which I
'll read now, and for that I'll need my
glasses for a moment: the
superworld, uh, the
realm of the rich and
privileged society, which is the scene of
effective influence exerted on the
government by private power. Although the
superworld is not
institutionalized or
formally authorized to exert such influence,
it includes, firstly, those whose influence is
exerted through their wealth, whether
administered personally or more
traditionally through
tax-exempt foundations and the
projects they support. And
secondly, the representatives of the first—
this term must be distinguished from
Friedrich Lundberg's—the super-rich,
that is to say, the 60  The
wealthiest families in the United States, which he erroneously predicted
in
1967 in his book *The 1967 Family* would
continue to dominate the
United States as much as the class and
government of
money, are shown in recent rankings
by Forbes magazine of the 400
richest Americans. This demonstrates
that Lunberg was wrong
on two counts: the wealthiest
heirs of the 1967 generation are
not, by any means, the richest people
today, and the richest people
today are not necessarily
those who
project their wealth onto
political power. Furthermore, the
upper class is not a class but
a category—this is very important. One
must not think that this class is
unified. The rich
know each other, but they do not act in a
unified way.
It is wrong to conceive of
the influence of the
upper class, as exercised through
the
Bilderberg Group, the Trilateral Commission, or
the Council on
Foreign Relations, as an institutional rule. However, there are
Lesser-known and usually
secretive cabals thrive within these
high-society circles. For example, in France, the
Piné Circle or the Safari Club—that's my
definition. It's true they are
organized. It's true that there are,
for example, Davos every year,
the Bilderberg Group, the
Trilateral Commission, and the very existence
of all these different organizations
indicates a rather
pluralistic than unified situation. But in the
middle of it all, you really have to realize
that, for
example, not everyone knows this, but
it's true that in
1974, I believe, the Wilson government in
England was overthrown, ousted, and also
de Gaulle, at the end of his term,
had problems with his intelligence service.
And we later learned that there was
a Piné Circle that
was proud of the party that had been able to
elect Mrs. Thatcher in England.
And so, there are not
just organizations, but even
deep powers in the middle of this high-society
world because the power of money
is very, very strong. For example,  We
know very well that there were two
oil price hikes, the
first in
'72, I'd say '19-72-13, and the second in
'79-'80. We know that Nixon was
responsible for the first one because it
helped his projects to
settle the
Iranian Gulf region—do we say the Gulf?—because
the programs for Iran and
Saudi Arabia, which came from the
oil price hikes, paid for their
import of American weapons, with
teams
to teach the use of these
weapons and all that. The second one, obviously
under President Carter, didn't help
his
policy at all; on the contrary, it was
responsible for his downfall. But I believe
that the Republicans had
contacts in the oil-producing countries, and
perhaps Bippi in particular,
encouraged OPEC to raise the price
of oil. And in this way, we saw
the almost simultaneous election of Sergey in
England and then also Rean in the
United States. And really, the election of
President
Rean was the  The beginning of a new
era in the United States, marked by a
significant increase in subsidies for
military budgets and the
CIA's operating budget. The CIA even started
a war in Afghanistan, and
we're seeing a result
in civil society. Before
1980, the rich and poor classes
were approaching each other in terms of income; there was
a decrease in the disparity between
rich and poor. But since that
year, since 1980,
it's the opposite: now the
rich are getting much richer
and the poor much poorer.
We are now in a more precarious position than Europe,
statistically
speaking. Before 1940,
England was a
class-based country with rich and poor, and
the United States less so. Now it's the
opposite: America is more divided
between rich and poor than
England, or almost any
other country in Europe, except Russia.
When I talk about the superpower, you should
n't think that the superpower is
divided by a
huge gap.  Well, not from the government, it's
the source of people, especially in
the past. People entered from the upper echelons,
they entered the
government, and especially the position of, uh,
Secretary of the Treasury, Secretary of the
Treasury, as we say,
uh, but there was also an institution in the
middle of the government that
received much more of the thinking, the
direction from Wall Street than the rest of the
government, and that was the CIA. The
CIA, uh, when it was created, it was
really a Wall Street creation.
Truman was the president; he wasn't very comfortable
with this idea of ​​having
an intelligence service in
peacetime conditions, but it was Wall
Street that insisted. CIA, Wall Street, that
won. And it's very interesting to
see that Truman insisted that the chief
in his time, the chief, was
never from Wall Street, always from
Central America,
especially from the
military, before Allan Dallas, who was
obviously pure Wall Street,
uh, there was never a chief who
came from Wall Street, but the
deputy chiefs, all the deputy chiefs that we
We know SEP, I know SEP, they
were all on Wall Street, and in addition there's what's called
the Society Register, which
means people of inherited wealth, uh, the
great society of New York, 6 of this 7, was part
of this society, this Social Register.
So from the beginning it was a
creation of Wall Street, and finally,
for technical reasons that I
discuss in my
book, *American War Machine*, it was
Trump who brought in Allan
Dallas as one of his deputy chiefs in the
CIA. But the moment the Republicans
finally won the presidency in
1952, it was the end of the army chiefs,
George Beatles Smith, and it's the
beginning of the Dallus era, a
Dallus who was at the CIA, and Are Dallus, his
brother, who was the Secretary of State. And it's at
this time that we saw a
pure Wall Street policy, beginning
with,
uh, assistance in uplifting the
president-elect in Iran, Mr. Mossadeq,
to ​​save the
Anglo-Iranian oil company, which is now called
BP, and secondly, immediately after
in Guatemala
to
save United Fruit
against
another elected president, Arbens,
elected not in a
ticking way. It must be remembered that Truman,
in
creating the CIA, thought it would be
an intelligence service to
find out
information from all countries, but from the very
beginning, under the direction of people
from Wall Street, they got involved in
operations—that is to say,
criminal operations in general—in the
rest of the world because it was partly due to the
Soviet threat
at the time. The first Operation C was to
put money into the Italian election
of 1948,
and it was said that the Russians
were doing the same thing, so they had to
do the same thing. But in
the 1950s, yes, all the
CIA's major operations
were for the good of Wall Street,
and we don't know that because
the CIA also got involved in
Southeast Asia, starting first in
Thailand, then Burma, then
Laos, and finally, on a much larger scale,
Vietnam. I would say that from the
From the very
beginning, the
CIA interventions were for the goals
defined by Wall Street. First,
we're talking about the
Council on
Foreign Relations, which had a
discussion about what should be done in
Guatemala before the CIA got involved. So,
first, a
discussion in New York, a decision, and then a
decision communicated to
Washington. This was under
Eisenhauer, who was very willing;
he agreed. But the way to
influence policy was
primarily through the CIA, and it was
executed by the CIA. And I see the same
thing later with Vietnam because,
for me, Vietnam was the
real reason for intervening in Vietnam in
1966. It was because,
with the technical developments in
oil exploration, for the
first time, oil could be found
under the sea. And we
knew from the beginning of the
1950s that there was a lot of oil
in, under, the Chinese sea, the
sea between Vietnam and
Indonesia. And we see...  This
era of major US interventions
in Vietnam and Indonesia, and after that,
the signing of contracts with
American companies to
develop oil under the sea in
Vietnam, Cambodia, Thailand, and
especially
Indonesia, is when I really began
my research by looking for the reason
why the Americans
intervened in
Indonesian politics in
1965. The result was a massive massacre
of perhaps millions of people—
civilians, women, children, entire classes,
institutions, schools—because they
were part of a communist party,
but a fairly peaceful one
that hoped to win an election. This was one of the
major
interventions by the United States, not
only the CIA but also the
American military, with all sorts of
things involved. But it was for
oil, for the
region's natural resources. We talked about rubber, we
talked about tungsten,
all of that wasn't wrong.
It was especially important to note that one of the biggest, least
discussed, but very important,
resources was tungsten. I don't know
the word in French; I hope it's...
Tungsten is tungsten in English, and
it's absolutely necessary for
strong steel, for components in
armored vehicles, and so on. It was absolutely
essential, and at that time it came
from China, which is
now out of the question, and also from
Southeast Asia. That was also true, but
oil has overtaken the others, I think,
especially rubber, because now
most of our rubber comes from oil. It's
artificial,
and we'll see in the statistics that
trade between Southeast Asia
and America was based on oil.
The investments we saw in
Southeast Asia
also came largely from Japan, but Japan's
economy after the war was also
a creation of the
Americans because we think that at that time
American policy was
defined by the Cold War against
Russia and the Soviet Union. We wonder to what
extent this
Cold War was real and to what extent it was
a kind of mask for the
more capitalist reasons of Wall
Street. My personal opinion  I've thought about it a
lot because I was
young at the time, but I
remember it well: partly, the
fear of the Soviet Union was real, and
true. That is to say,
I don't believe the Soviet Union would ever have
invaded Western Europe with its
divisions into Eastern Europe, and that's
the great myth of NATO. And when
I was...  In the government, I
started to question this myth. I didn't
believe it at the time, and I don't believe it
now, but I believe it's very, very
possible that the communist parties
in Italy and France would have won
their elections. It's because the
CIA intervened to prevent this
result that we now see a
non-communist Europe. And from my
personal point of view, I don't like the
methods that were used to
protect Western Europe, but I
'm very glad that we do
n't see a France that suffered the same
post-war policies as, for
example, Poland, because I lived
in Poland. It wasn't so bad; I
knew people in the
socialist government, they were my
friends, but it was
sad for Poland.
And I'm glad that Poland is
now free from Russian influence.
And for me personally, I believe
that the events in France would have been just as
sad if the communists had been
put in power. These are
subjects that are very difficult to
discuss,
but I said all this to admit
that there was a  There was an element of truth at the
beginning of the Cold War, but
it's also important to see that as this
war developed, it was increasingly
influenced by the private interests of the
global elite.
I'll
now include the major
international corporations of the time,
which were primarily
oil corporations like Standard Oil, what
we now call Exodus Mobile, and
Texaco.
The Cold War evolved over
the years into
a way to protect the interests of
these large
corporations, not
exclusively in Europe, but partly in Europe
with the Truman Doctrine. To
guarantee a non-communist Greece, it was
accepted at the time that this was to ensure
that Saudi Arabian oil
could be sold in Europe
because
the major corporations didn't
want it to come from the
United States, since they still had
domestic production here.
This oil had to go to
Europe, and for that, a
non-communist Greece was necessary. That was the
beginning of a mixing of interests.  Between the
real Cold War and the interests
of the Corporation, but later it was
almost purely the corporations,
yes, I just wrote a short article
on the current situation in mid-
2013 in Syria because it's a choice
that has been repeated many times in
American history: a choice between a
military policy and a diplomatic policy. It was
at the beginning of
May that the United States and Russia agreed
that they needed to
agree on a convention, perhaps in
Geneva, to seek an
international diplomatic solution to the
Syrian problems, which were becoming increasingly
serious and threatening to escalate beyond
Syrian borders and create a
crisis
in Lebanon, Iraq, and even perhaps
Turkey,
because there are CDES (Councils of Economic and Social Rights) everywhere. And
I was very disappointed that Obama,
who was in a very narrow position, didn't
want to get involved
in this affair, but under
pressure from the fascists in Washington,
he
agreed to send weapons, small
arms.  But weapons, uh, to the fighters,
and that's a joke because
the CIA had already sent not
only weapons but also
specialists to train them. It's
a bit like Libya; there was
a secret policy that was already
underway. This policy is
very dangerous for an
international diplomatic solution. Hope isn't completely extinguished,
but it's
much weaker now. The
problem is that in Syria, as
in the other countries I've mentioned, there's
an oil problem. Now it's
increasingly gas. Before, it was oil,
now it's
increasingly gas. We've even
discovered gas in Syria. But what
's much more important
is what we call a gas field, a
gas field, a region of underground gas. It's
under the Gulf, which is shared
half by Qatar and half by Iran,
and it's the
largest region in the world. The market for
this gas will be Europe, and the
gas pipelines won't pass through  Israel will
go through Syria as usual. There was
the first
oil pipeline from Saudi Arabia that went through
Iraq and finally from Syria to the
Mediterranean. That was built a
long time ago. There was another pipeline
that was damaged during the Iraq War,
but now it's a choice. Qatar
told Mr. Assad in Syria, "
You must
resign. We want a
more Muslim government that would
allow our gas pipeline to pass
from Iraq to Turkey because there is
now a large gas pipeline.
When will the Nabuo Line be built
in Turkey? Qatar wanted to sell its
gas through this pipeline,
but at the same time, Iran
said, "We also want to take gas from
this same region and send it to
Europe through a pipeline that would pass through Iran
and Iraq because now Iraq is
much closer to Iran than before."
And
finally, Syria
and this war
between the government on one side and the
different factions,
including the rebels, are for a reason,
and it was subsidized mainly by
Qatar, which has already
paid.  I believe there's over 3 billion
dollars in subsidies for this
revolt because they want
Assad out to secure their
pipeline, but Assad is protected
now. He's starting to win with
the support of those who are directly
subsidized and partly directed by Iran.
Assad signed an
official contract with Iran for
a gas pipeline that would run
directly from Iran to a port—I think it's called the
Islamic Gas Pipeline—which will
now connect Iran to a
port that was previously quite small
but will certainly become much
larger because of the gas. Even there, even
in Syria,
and like the Great Britain, most
American interventions,
especially in
Libya and Iran, were about
oil and gas.
Syria is no exception; it was more
like Afghanistan.
Because when the
United States started to
take an interest in the
Taliban at the end of the
1980s, there was talk of...  of an
oil pipeline that would pass from
Kazakhstan to Pakistan through
Afghanistan, that's why Unocal, an
American company, invited people,
representatives of the Taliban, to come to
Texas to be taught
technical matters. It's always about
oil when we talk about
America and its Petrodollar, which is
the basis of its international wealth.
America is divided between hawks
and doves on the issue
of Syria. And in Europe, it's
the same situation, but there's an
even more serious division because there are
two kinds of interests in Europe.
Small countries like Austria in the East
want to have
gas as soon as possible; they don't want to
be under
too deep an influence from
Russia, so they invite
France, on the contrary, which has
historical interests in the region.
Austria is perhaps one of the
doves of Europe, and France
is currently one of the hawks of
Europe, as it was also in the
case of Libya.  Bernard Levi, who
in a sense initiated all the
problems in Libya in
2000-2011, is why these
gas and oil problems
are not simple. They create
regional alliances, and especially
Russia has a rather complicated position regarding
this oil pipeline because
I imagine Russia preferred to avoid
both the Qatari and
Iranian pipelines, as the
gas market is not
infinite and is limited. Currently, it's
Russian gas. To conclude,
I would like to say something to the
young people attending this interview.
I would like to talk about why
I do my research and
investigations. First, I
come from Canada, which is
a fairly small country in terms of
population. In Canada, we have
the impression that if we have an idea
to improve the country, we can
share it with leaders in Ottawa,
with members of the Canadian Parliament.
And in fact, I did this a little bit
when I was young.  Even before
the age of 20,
and when I arrived in the
United States, I had the same illusion, but
you know very well that it's not the
same in the United States as, and there are
more people in California alone, I
think, than in all of Canada. So it's on a completely
different scale. And I must say that, if
I had the idea at the beginning, I was
fighting against intervention in the
Vietnam War. From my career in
diplomacy, I knew a little bit about
the Vietnamese situation,
not much, but enough to
convince me that the United States should
not enter this war, for
American health as much as for
Vietnamese health.
And I learned that a whole
movement, thousands,
almost millions, in the end, they
helped a little to end
this war,
but
my
personal contribution was very, very
small, and I don't feel now
that my ideas are going to change
the United States, not at all. But still,
I'm very happy to be doing what
I'm doing. I meet people who
I love being here with people. I'm in a
room here with friends I
met through a movement, and through
these
movements I meet people I love. I also always have this
idea that even if
I do
n't contribute to
current policies, there's always the
politics of the future, and maybe
I can persuade other people to be like
me, interested in international justice,
personal freedom, and democracy. It's
on the screen at the
Washington level; it's a very bad
movement, a very bad time
now for justice, freedom, and
democracy. But still, I see
that
Washington's bad policies are creating opposition, and I
absolutely want to be part of
that opposition because I have faith
in humanity, that we have a
tendency towards
democracy, towards freedom,
and towards the joy of being free in
a free and open society.
I'm very disappointed if I didn't think
I could contribute even a little bit
to that future, and I
hope that among you, you
young people, I'll be there too.  Well, there will be
people who will have the same hope of
participating in the future of our country, of
our globe, and of our
human race. Thank you very much.
And there is currently a
situation that we wouldn't have foreseen
20 years ago. In fact, there's a comparison between
the United States with its
universal surveillance
and East Germany during the
Stasi era, where the same thing existed. And this is
one of the major indications that
since 9/11 we have
really seen a big change in the United States.
We wouldn't have foreseen this
universal surveillance, and that was
a result of what we
call Continuity of Government
Arrangements (COG),
which had been
planned for 20 years by a
group of people, partly in the
government and partly outside. The most
interesting thing is that two of these people
who planned it were Donald Ramsfeld
and Richard Shane, who was in power in
Washington on 9/11.
President Bush was in Florida, and
these two people started
implementing the
Continuity of Government Provisions.  They
can be summarized in three
categories: first,
universal surveillance without a court warrant;
second, and
I believe much worse, indefinite detention without a
warrant; and third,
the permanent intervention of
the military in
domestic security in the
United States. Points 2 and 3 were
against existing laws, one
could even say against the United States Constitution. It
really needs to be explained to a
French audience that the idea of
indefinite detention without a warrant contravenes one of the
deepest and
most
traditional freedoms of the
Anglo-Saxon tradition. This was granted by
Magna Carter in
1215, and since then we have had what is
called habus corpus, which
states that someone is
detained for 24 to 48 hours. But soon,
it becomes necessary to produce
the person who was detained. And although
I believe it's horrible that we
now have
universal surveillance to find
terrorists, we have found perhaps
twenty  Around fifty, it depends on
your definition,
but certainly fewer than 500
terrorists in the United States.
Everyone is monitored,
constantly, all the time, and this has
become an excuse to control the
public in
general, to create a situation very, very
similar to what the
novelist George Orwell warned about in
his novel
1994. He got the date wrong, but he
really did warn about what we have
now in the United States. And also the
third
point: the permanent intervention of the military in
domestic security. There are also
specifically American laws, like the ones that
prohibited this, and all of that
changed, apparently forever, at 10:00
AM on September 11th when Charles and
Romsfield implemented the
provisions for continued operation.
The result is that we
have the public state
as before, but we
now have a second state, a
secret state, or as we are
increasingly saying, a deep state, which is
not governed by the
Supreme Court, which makes its own laws.
There  Now, there are some
very technical questions, and I won't go into
those issues in this
speech, but it's not just
me talking about a deep state in the United States
now. Even
academics are saying there was a coup d'
état on September 11th because it's such a
change in the
country's political situation. It's true that we need to
recognize similarities
with the situation in
East Germany. And for a country like America, which was
born in
conditions of revolution against
an
absolutist government in London that didn't listen to
local interests, it's
truly dramatic to see the
change we've seen in this
country. It's very sad. But we
mustn't think that the
public is dead, that the public has forgotten
the idea of
freedom. It's very difficult to
generalize about the situation in the
United States, and the moment we think we
understand this...  What's happening in the
United States is the moment when a
new movement appears elsewhere, one that wasn't expected,
and that's why I have no doubt
that the government will
correct the
current situation, but I
truly believe that there will finally be
change
coming from the public, from people like me
and my friends in the
anti-war movement. There aren't many guys like Kusac,
this
incredible Adonis-like figure who, looking everyone
in the eye,
said, "I'm not lying, you
can believe me," and so on. There was something about it: how can we
imagine that a
politician will be able to say, "
No, no, wait, the general interest is
the defense of fundamental freedoms. A
fundamental freedom is the defense of
privacy," and there's a
conflict there. It's impossible to call for
compassion in France. The problem is that
the word "compassion" is demonized. We
simply forget that these are people who
prioritize results over
methods, and who...  are capable of gaining
an intimate knowledge of a system